let's move on now to the late bob saget
yesterday marked one month since he
passed and his family is revealing the
heartbreaking cause of bob's death
head trauma is cited as the cause of
bob's untimely passing in a statement to
e.t his family including wife kelly
rizzo shared the news that bob
accidentally hit the back of his head on
something thought nothing of it and went
to sleep older people are at higher risk
for grain bleed in this case bob saget
was 65 so he may have been at higher
risk or something like this
neuroscientist dr ben ryan says while
the details of bob's head trauma are
unknown his death might have been
preventable if you do hit your head you
should probably call someone go to the
emergency room and you can just have a
quick scan done we're told no drugs or
alcohol were involved however according
to the autopsy report bob was also covet
positive bob was open about battling
coronavirus near the end of 2021 and
it's possible to continue to test
positive for up to 90 days after
isolating i don't know if i had delta or
i might have had a combo maybe at one
point they were working together
meanwhile close friend john mayer
revealed he's writing a song in bob's
memory the test of healing is that i can
get through the sentence most of the
time i just loved him so much john spoke
to andy cohen just before his serious xm
small stage series concert last night in
l.a at one point john stopped the show
after noticing a fan having a medical
issue are they conscious
they're calm give me a thumbs up if
they're alert
okay
after walking off stage to make sure the
woman was okay john returned a few
minutes later with an update anyone in
the crowd who's worried i'm told that
she's up and waved goodbye
now new details about bob odenkirk and
the heart attack he had on the set last
july i'm not gonna lie it hurts the
better call saul star says it took three
defibrillator shocks to correct his
pulse after collapsing the 59 year old
tells the new york times luckily i
didn't go back to my trailer after
shooting scenes he says being around his
co-stars like ray seahorn who called for
help likely saved his life
[Music]
you